what I'm shaking right oh my god well I
just remember loving the 90s I was a 90s
kid I think my favorite fashion trend
from the 90s where you would wrap the
the plaid the oversized plaid shirt
around your waist I still do that to
this day and they know that style stuff
might come back yeah now when I look
back and I see pictures from when I was
a kid I feel like I looked ridiculous oh
[Music]
my god the maxi boys this is just the
epitome of the 90s the oversized baggy
pants the belt I probably wear one of
these vest stuff still I still would
like to look back and I can't believe
that we thought that this was fashion
back that night
[Music]
what is this can I open this I feel
really awkward you ready for this I
wanted the Super Soaker so bad I was
shaking right now
can I can I open sorry I am I'm
forgetting myself right now my dad was
like I'm not paying for that so we were
just like we'd make these cheap versions
we just fill up like a two-liter bottle
of soda with water or whatever and you'd
screw a hole in the top then you just
ran around and squeezing it at each
other so ever since I was a kid I've
always wanted my own kitchen set I
remember even like being in preschool
and like trying to play with they had a
kitchen set in the preschool but it was
like the most popular toy and I never
got to play with it cuz like the kids
would always run and get to it before me
and so I always kind of wanted my own my
neighbor's I remember had them on the
Super Soaker 50 was the first one and we
do there was one night I remember this
like it was yesterday and we all stayed
out till like 10 o'clock at night which
when you're like 8 years old that might
as well be 2 a.m. and we just had a big
old water fight and it was amazing I had
a bunch of hand-me-down toys cuz I was
the youngest and so I just kind of like
had makeshift stuff and so I just wanted
like my own real like kitchen set I
didn't put it to play and I had
imaginary friends that I wanted to
invite over yeah this is just like the
thing that I've always wanted if it is
too expensive like it's huge this is
what I wanted I would love to fill this
up right now and just go to town around
the office
you gotta be strong okay do we have
water anywhere
take that dad I'm so surprised I don't
know I was shaking like this is really
surreal oh this is great I'm not gonna
spray it in here but I might can i play
[Laughter]
so we just got done assembling this
amazing kitchen set it's actually kind
of set up like a coffee shop I'm still
like a little speechless right now like
this is amazing and I'm seeing and
remembering exactly why I wanted
something like this as a kid and I can
just imagine myself spending hours with
this you've got your baked goods I just
want to point out the detail and
everything too like they have these
coffee they have the sleeves for the
coffee mug and this is a really freaking
fun still though oh look at it and it
goes like the afar blast radius oh I
know for a fact that as a child as a
young lady I would have spent hours upon
hours just playing with this I probably
would have had my friends over and we
would have had a restaurant because we
did play restaurant at my friend's house
but we never had anything like this we
just use their imagination reach for the
sky sir
[Applause]
[Music]
coming right up
oh yeah that'll be 875 fresh off the
oven would you also like to coffee yes
[Music]
yeah so big thing as a kid for me was
just like making sure the set I guess
everything was set up so carefully and
everything looked right and so just why
I'm interested in such a sign once
everything was just so they doesn't like
spend like ten minutes actually it
definitely met my expectations I want
more people to get these so that we can
have a nice water gun fight one of these
days like once it gets hot out again but
yeah this is this is great I still had
no idea that this is a maybe a surprise
so it's made my day it still has that
nostalgic and it still has that like it
definitely lives up to the expectations
just because of the whole the details
and everything that they have like you
have an assortment of baked goods you
have a little door where you can have
like an oven you have a little fridge
yeah every little coffee mug like
there's just it has all of the things
that would keep me occupied for hours my
dad was like really resourceful so I
liked the fact that he just made we
still had a lot of fun to just spraying
the you know empty soda bottles were at
each other but yeah and I feel like I
got a lot of my resourcefulness from him
and and all that so but now it's good to
finally have a real one I'm definitely
gonna find some more from some of my
friends you could have a summer day just
doing this definitely living up think
that everything I would have expected
and wanted and more I love this
[Music]
look at this this is a pop-tart
[Music]